live with episode number 14 of the
podcast with
our buddy here adam sosnick and our new
friend hello
jarrah hutchins aka j is what her
friends call her that's what they call
me
and our friend sam here has learned in
the last 24 hours how to pronounce
fort lauderdale how did sam say it now
correctly
he almost had it by the way no say it
again because he's colombian sadie again
fourth laravel there you go okay for for
all my party friends out there how also
do you say
fort lauderdale he forgot about it for
like
dale for liquor dale because you get
liquored up and the reason why he had to
learn
the reason but the reason why he had to
learn how to say fort lauderdale
because he's got a flight to fort
lauderdale today so he's are you going
for the first time or no
yes sir unfortunately we may not see you
back here because if he takes you to the
wrong places you may stick around
you're going to meet a colombian from
colombia even though you're from
colombia and all of a sudden you know
that's a whole
different story of colombia anyways okay
so
uh why do we bring jarrah today let's
talk about why we brought jerome what
we're going to talk about today so jared
so last week not last week two weeks ago
luis when was the class that we took
september 10th the 10th yeah so the 10th
we decide
because i come in and i'm talking to uh
it's not every day you talk to your hr
person and say hey
uh i want to have a license to carry
class at the home office this is not not
every company wants to do things like
this
but i said i want to do something and if
anybody wants to participate dude who do
you recommend
she was all on board this was my idea
okay because when aaron called me you
know you know aaron stanwix and i have
known each other for a long time
yeah she told me i could see it so she i
said listen this is what i want to do
and i said i think i want other people
to get it as well because i think
times are getting a little crazy so she
says i know the right person
i said who's the right person he says
this is my friend i said okay put it on
no problem and i've been to so many
classes and i go to these classes i'm
bored out of my mind when i hear some
people teaching stuff
and then you walk in 15 of us are
sitting there just everybody knows our
buddy here
uh luis luis luis brought his mom his
grandma his grandfather his brother
his sister his cousin you had
two-year-olds
he said everybody in this family is
gonna help
when he when he sent in his payment all
the family members didn't even fit
in the in the memo
why so many people in your family why
tell me why uh just because i want them
all to be safe and the time
for you crazy i like it and then kai
from norway
led the way we have to recognize kai
because kai led the way with the most
questions i think kai asked
50 questions and we're like listen buddy
we want to keep this to four hours kai
dragged it out to four and a half hours
he was also the first person to sign up
what's he really yeah kai was like on it
wow so pro second amendment from norway
to sign up for can pay
norway and if we can get the right angle
on kai today from this camera i would
love for the audience to compliment kai
on his hairdo today because he looks
legit today to the 12
of our audience that are women kai is
single just so you know off man i like
that kai
single and he does swipe right so
anyways okay so let's let's uh let's
continue what we're gonna what are we
gonna talk about today since we have an
expert on this topic
what jarrah does is she teaches a
license she's an instructor firearms
instructor in fort hood
and helps people like us get a license
to carry in the state of texas
what she also does on top of that is
human trafficking which she'll tell some
of the story just so everybody knows
uh she went to sleep last night at six
o'clock because she was working last
night so
she's going on fumes today our buddy
adam hasn't had any sleep all night last
night okay he's got deep thoughts about
his future his life
and then i haven't had a lot of sleep
either so we're going to talk about her
since she's a person
personal protection officer level three
about to be a level four
so we're going to talk about firearm
sales we're going to talk about brianna
taylor's a
tragic event that took place recently um
censoring of second amendment amendment
at corporate world uh operation
underground railroad we'll talk railroad
uh we will talk about all this stuff as
weapon stuff gun stuff oh my gosh all
three pages kai put up tesla in there
we're going to talk about
we do have tesla that's right elon musk
tesla they want to sell a 25 000 auto
tesla
and then american household collectively
their net worth
climbed seven percent in q2 219 trillion
dollars
which is pretty good yeah to see
people's networks increasing
nike share has soared 13 percent
uh carvana share sword the uh you know
surged 30 percent
barr announced 100 million dollars more
to combat human trafficking
and then uh cindy mccain apparently is
not a fan of uh
uh uh trump and she will be voting for
joe biden a democrat she has
the last time she voted democrat she was
18 years old so a long time ago the last
time she voted democrat and she said
she's going to be voting for biden over
trump which we'll
talk about that as well there was some
intense meetings going on at the u.n and
obviously the most important topic today
that we have to talk about is
mike tyson's voting for the first time
if you didn't know mike tyson will be
voting for the first time and
everybody's wondering who he's going to
be voting for because prior to this
he couldn't vote due to his felony
record now he can finally vote and we
can kind of talk about who mike tyson's
going to vote for but i think it's
appropriate
for us to take a quick moment here and
and gerald why don't you take a quick
moment and share with the rest of us
why uh you know one thing i liked the
most when you opened up the
class you talked about the importance of
having a license to carry
and you shared this story about your
experience what happened in orlando
that i think if anybody's listening to
this whether you're married
whether it's for you if you have a
sister if you got a daughter if you got
a mother if you got anybody
has to hear the story that jarrah shared
with the rest of us sure tell us what
happened with you while you decided to
get a license to carry
well i was uh in a i was
in orlando uh years and years ago and uh
coming back
from a vacation there and one of the
uh guys that was handling uh the baggage
uh took a picture of my luggage tag with
his cell phone
and in orlando in orlando so you're
checking in your bag
he takes a picture because your dr your
license is on it
yeah i mean your your what do you call
it your address is on it
okay address name i mean what do you put
on there you know you're you want
if you lose your bag you want
you want to be able to find it you know
you want you know so all you're going to
just blindly put you know all of that
information on there right
you naturally put it assuming you can
you know trust the airlines
and you think about you know who you
know you think about who who's working
in baggage
uh i'm not saying bad people working
baggage i'm just saying like you're
thinking about
like just random strangers are they got
all your info
right they they got your address they
got your email address they got your
phone number
your name i mean i'm not hard to find
anyway i got a weird name but
um yeah so uh the you know the guy
started reaching out to me and
you know kind of telling me that we were
sort of destined to be together
hold on what the guy he was a baggage
handler he was at the airport
and just started he was actually the guy
that checked in the bags
he wasn't necessarily the baggage
handler he saw me he had a conversation
with me
so while he was checking in my bag so
the person we go to
to give our banks to and get our flight
uh what do you call it the
the uh uh your boarding pass the
boarding pass
that's the person you're talking about
that's a trip right now and he starts
texting you
emailing you what calling you freaking
myspace to me you know like my feeling
is a long time ago
and uh what year uh it was paint the
picture for us
i was 23 2003
that was 20 no it was 23 so it would
have been don't date yourself
six years ago 21 years 38 i'm 38 now
i've never seen a woman just announce
her age like this oh she said it on
stage she was so comfortable
i think it was 2004. this is the height
of myspace
facebook isn't a thing yet yeah jared's
traveling doing her thing
and some guys thinks he's destined to be
with you yeah continue please
and uh so it's yeah so it's interesting
the kind of the kind of people that
handle
our personal information and another you
know before i get to it another
interesting thing to note is
you know a lot of airlines you know if
you check your gun
on your baggage you know you can do that
you can do it in your check package we
learned that in class
and uh you know they they used to want
you to have a tsa lock
on there right so that they could look
into your you know look in your stuff
make sure you have it packed right right
well then tsa started stealing people's
guns
so now they you know a lot of airlines
want you to have you got it you got to
declare it they got to look at it
right and then they want you to lock it
up and have the key
right so the people that we're supposed
to trust you know this this organization
that was you know
brought out of 911 right now that you're
still in people's guns
so it's like who do you trust november
one when they came out by the way tsa
yeah only if you think about it tsa has
only been on for 19 years yeah
you some people think tsa has been
around for a long time it used to be a
private uh
uh uh organization that would do the
security work now it's tsa 19 years only
you're saying november of 2001. november
of two two months right after 9 11.
is when bush came out with the tsa got
it
crazy so anyway yeah so he was reaching
out and
um it was you know it wasn't welcome and
i was
living on my own and uh he showed up to
the house
middle of the night not middle of the
night but
you know at night at night probably
eight nine o'clock and then what
happened you know
uh he was greeted with the business end
of a shotgun
this is great but not by you or by your
boyfriend at the time
no i was home alone so by your shotgun
what was his reaction
uh fear as it should be
yeah i can only imagine and um it was uh
you know and after after that here i
started to think to myself now another
another thing too
um you know and but yeah i don't know if
this is tmi but um this was kind of the
second
you know really crappy thing to you know
happened to me out so i was raped as a
teenager
and i didn't want so that you know after
that i started to think to myself you
know
i can't the people that i'm supposed to
be able to trust
to keep me safe right uh you know my
parents
the police the government you know and
i'm not poo pooing on any of those
people
i'm just saying that the people that we
sort of naturally look to to keep us
safe
can't do it it's it's it's impossible
and it's not necessarily that they don't
want
to it's that they cannot it's it's
physics does not allow for it okay
and so we we have to you know was kind
of at that point where i said
i've got to kind of maybe be an a better
ambassador for my safety right and a
better
first responder to myself and so i
started to you know and i grew up around
guns i grew up in a family that was
about guns uh but i didn't really have a
lot of handgun experience
i was a hunter you know growing up so i
always kind of had the shotgun why i
can't strap a shotgun in my back and you
know go where
you know go get my nails done and go to
the movies and all that crap you know so
i gotta
figure out you know what do i need to do
about this and so i started kind of
looking into uh what it would take for
me to get a handgun license in texas and
you know
that particular education because i
certainly didn't want to shoot my foot
off
but you know so i needed to get i needed
to get educated and so i
did that and it was a very painful
brutal
experience because i was being taught uh
you know
no offense but i was being taught by men
who didn't want to teach me
you know i did they didn't you know it
was it was frustrating to teach me it
was
it wasn't cool to teach me right because
i'm not you know i'm not a
tactical tommy you know person you know
i don't have military experience i
wasn't a
you know a police officer and so i'm
literally starting from scratch i'm like
i don't even know i don't know what that
is
you know i don't know how this works and
so uh it was you know then you know
sometimes when you're at a certain level
and you got to go back to the basics
it's it can be
you know frustrating and boring right
you can you want to keep going forward
you don't necessarily want to go back
and so when i finished that um
sort of education and felt comfortable
going to the range on my own
uh and you know carrying a gun i started
to get you know some of my female
friends were like hey i see you know hey
i saw and you were at the gun range you
know
maybe you can take me i'm kind of
interested in this and so it started out
me teaching my friends
and then i would you know they would
tell their friends that i didn't know or
whatever and then
you know it kind of turned into a
part-time gig and then i said you know
what i want to start teaching license to
carry because
i got a perspective on this i got things
to say about this
and so i went down i signed up to go
down to the dps class it's a two-day
class uh down in florence right outside
of austin
and uh 180 people came to this class to
get license to carry they only do it
like once a year
two women wow it was me and a gal that
had just
courtney that had just uh retired from
the navy
now do you notice a trend with women who
want to get a license to carry or know
is there a
is is there a trend with a tragic event
that took place where they said no one's
ever going to do this to me again
yeah it's there's a lot of that okay
there's a lot of that
and um so you know that when you take
this class the the guys that teach it
are
it was actually a phenomenal class i
thought it was going to be very boring
and kind of like you right and
you thought he was going to be born i
thought she was she oh you thought she
was going to be born
and i said there's zero boringness going
on
there's a lot of action going on and so
uh but they tell you
over and over again um you know when you
take this class they say to you
you're never going to make a full-time
living doing this
this has to be it's a side hustle it's a
passion project it's a community effort
and it is
all of those things okay but i'm sitting
there and i'm listening to this guy and
i'm like you know i'm like 17 rows up in
the stadium seating in this place
and i'm going hold my beer
because you don't hold my beer buddy let
me show you what's going on
like you haven't seen what i've seen you
don't have the perspective that i have
because i'm gonna get this license and
i'm gonna go
into an underserved market because you
don't even you're not you're not digging
in this market
you're not you're not you're not going
out and you're not hearing what what
women
are dealing with in their own safety and
they don't
feel empowered to do it they're they're
they
learn different than men you know guys
are like guns i just want to pull a
trigger
you know and women are like i need a
checklist okay i need this is
this is where i want you know how do i
know where to start and how do i know
when i'm done
like they need to know that they need
they want that structure because there's
a fear factor there right
go deeper on that like with the mindset
of a man getting a gun license versus a
female i'd love to
hear hear more about that you know there
a lot of men are um
they're not even you know they're not uh
necessarily
in in the mindset of i need a formal
education
they're like just show me how to do it
you know what i mean and
women want to know like what what's the
statistics
of the of me you know ever having to do
this or
you know or and or with a lot of women
it's the question has never been posed
so when i when i teach when i teach
introduction handgun for instance
um and i do a lot of ladies-only classes
for that and i teach men too but
you know the first question that i ask
when i sit down is i go listen how many
of you in here
are moms okay and it's most of the
people that take that class
and i say to them do you think in
reality because we talk a lot we talk a
lot of [ __ ] right we talk we say
you know uh mama bear you know don't
mess with me there's a lot of water
cooler talk between the mamas about what
they would do if somebody ever mess with
their kid
but i say in reality would you really be
able to pull it off
with a physical altercation
when your kid's lives are at stake what
would you do
and could you do it okay i'm not saying
you have this
from mom oh yeah and i'm like i'm not
asking you if you would have the
gumption
to do it i'm asking you can you pull it
off
i'm asking you can a girl can a woman my
size
take down a man your size and the answer
is always no
because the question's never been posed
to them that way nobody goes up to a
pregnant woman
and says hey when you have that baby do
you think you're ever going to be able
to physically defend it
nobody ever asks that question and it's
a question that needs to be asked it's
some and it's and it doesn't need and we
don't need to wait until we're about to
start a family we need to start asking
our daughters this when they're little
when they're younger
okay when they get to be teenagers and
they start doing stuff on their own we
need to start
training our kids not necessarily to be
you know the you know warriors and
fighters you know but we need to say
look you need to start paying attention
to what's going on around you and we
need to be good examples of that as
parents
you know and as adults in their life you
know like i don't have any biological
kids but
i have a lot of kids in my life and this
this is the question that aunt jarrah
is posing to them all the time is pay
attention to what you're doing
pay attention to what's going on around
you assess your environment often
not to the point of paranoia but to the
point of preparedness and so
i have i have literally built a business
a viable business on teaching
people how to not die
and that's insane to me that's that is
insane by the way there's a little bit
of static on the speaker i don't know if
you're getting it or not there's
that it's a lot now yeah oh
i don't know where it's coming from
we've never had this
this is a first so okay
you're gonna do what you're gonna unplug
this one okay
go with another one is it mine no go
ahead
okay let's see can you hear still a lot
of static
guys okay somebody's in the audience
i think i think uh i think that's china
to be honest with you
they're hearing us they're hearing what
we're talking about jarrah's bringing
too much fire to the
show the audio system can't handle it we
are we are so if you
if you can hear us better now we'll get
back to it if you can't hear it just say
yes we're good to go
all right you're killing me someone says
you're killing me all right so they got
it can everyone hear us okay
okay guys give a like give a thumbs up
and let us know if you have any
questions
for jarrah over here and give a thumbs
up if so if you're feeling jarrah so
here's here's a question for you
is how many p how many women teach
license to carry classes not many not
many and and
for somebody that's listening to this
here's a couple things i'll tell you
okay from
from a perspective of somebody i talked
to where i you know we have the license
to carry conversation
one the conversation is first of all i
don't like having guns in my house
people there are people that don't even
want to have a conversation forget about
license to carry
it starts off with screw guns i don't
want any guns in my house
number two is if there's guns in my
house what if something happens or my
kids get a hold of it
and god forbid you know you hear about
all these accidents that happen with
kids and guns right
and then it's licensed to carry right
why do i need to have a license to carry
what's the benefit of me having a
license to care like who's going to come
and do anything to me right
so you know especially with all the
stuff that's going on right now with the
black lives matter with you know
defunding the police with brianna taylor
which we're going to get into here in a
minute
riot riots protesting election all of
this stuff that's going on
why do you think it's important for
somebody to have a gun and let alone
have a license to carry
because physics dictates that the only
people
that are going to be able to
purposefully respond to a situation of
duress are the people that are already
there
i mean that's it and that's that's
science it's uh
indisputable it's very important what
you just said can you say that one more
time what you just said
because physics dictates that the only
people that are going to be able to
purposefully respond to a situation of
duress are the people that are already
there
and so you nobody's going to show up and
you know how many
how many things do you see on social
media where you know
somebody's getting their ass whipped in
the middle of the street and people are
just filming it nobody's helping
yeah all the time you know so people are
you know people are more about the drama
now you know than anything and
i think that there's a there's a fear
factor
about defending oneself that needs to go
away
right and the only way that that goes
away is with education it's all it
always has to be education before
legislation
because you're never going to legislate
out hate you're never gonna legislate
out crime
you're right you're never gonna
legislate somebody into an opinion so
you gotta you know you gotta change
hearts and minds that's the only way to
do it
and you and the only way that you do
that is through education
and so what's uh what's been an
interesting thing for me to see
over the last sort of 10 years that i've
been teaching this in about three years
full time
is the the mindset of women when they
first get to me in the mindset of women
when they leave when they leave my class
it's literally it's between it's either
one hour
three hours or like five hours that they
spend with me at a time right
and it's and the mindset when they when
they leave
is it's incredible to see the
transformation you know and they get to
the point where they're looking at me
and it's toward the end of class and i
can see it in their face that they're
going
i can do this i can i can think this way
i can manage my time this way because a
lot of women especially
don't understand that your your time
management
directly affects your safety so if your
life
is in disarray if you're constantly late
if you don't have a plan if you can't
keep a calendar
that is that right there is the
beginning of the end
of your safety that's that's powerful
what you're saying because what i did
when she said this that's the first
thing i do when you talk about physics
the reason why i had you repeatedly
because it's because in my mind
the first place i went to is what is the
average response time to cops showing up
when an event is taking place okay
could you guess what the average
response time is in america and i'll go
through the top states
depends on the neighborhood though but
give me give me average response time in
america from the moment you dialed 9-1-1
i have somebody in my house they just
robbed me i just said somebody pulled a
gun on me
how long do you think it is average
response time five minutes
27. three minutes three minutes u.s now
watch this
watch what happens here that's us right
three minutes
la is 5.7 minutes seattle
seven minutes dallas eight minutes we
live in dallas miami
eight minutes new york city 13.3 minutes
atlanta
nine minutes and 35 seconds houston 10
minutes detroit
12 minutes denver 15 minutes okay they
used to be 50 minutes now they're at 13
minutes
what can you do in three minutes a lot
but here's the thing
think about it that's if they have
somebody to send you
that's if somebody's available so i have
a quick story about this
so you know i dated a guy
a few years ago whose uh kids were
teenagers
and uh his ex-wife they had you know
50-50 custody
he had taught his kids how to shoot and
at the time his daughter was the oldest
and she was about
17. and they lived in uh
they lived actually not far from me in
the historic district of fort worth
fairmount okay
and it's right by the hospital district
and on the 10th floor of jps is the
psych ward
wow okay and uh so you know i had a
schizophrenic heroin addict break into
my house when i
when i lived there well while i was home
last october okay but that's
a different story we'll tell that in a
minute i was gonna say you get a lot of
so i get a lot of lunatics coming after
you
got a lot going on here okay but you got
like catnip for crazy going over here
yeah predisposed i guess sprinkling
jarrah
jared dust everywhere come here can't
help them so come get it
okay all right relax buddy all right
there was a
they were you know so so she was home
with her mom
it was like 11 o'clock at night some guy
just walks up the driveway and starts
trying to break in the house
starts trying to break in the garage
okay now
my ex had given his daughter or his wife
really his ex-wife
a 30-day special and he was like look
we're not together anymore we're not
living together anymore but you need to
be able to protect yourself and if she
did
she was not anti-gun can you tell adam
what a 38 special it's not like a
special gift on your 38th birthday
he was thinking like a birthday
does our audience know what a 38 special
i'm more concerned about you know what
the third is about
one right there too so it's a it's a
typical i mean you probably saw these a
lot in like 80s cop shows yeah i used to
watch dragnet i know that yeah
dan aykroyd very impressed yeah go ahead
gerald
so she has this 38 special so she's yeah
so you know
and she she wasn't you know super big
into guns but you know he says
hey you know ag knows how to use it okay
who's a.g
the daughter oh and uh you know
nobody ever thought anything of it well
you know so
this guy's breaking in the house right
so the mom she's calling 9-1-1 she's
like hey somebody's
breaking in my house like right now and
the fort worth police department says
i'm sorry man we don't have anybody to
send you
that's what they tell her okay so she's
in the fetal position
in the kitchen she's like you know
hiding in the kitchen right
aj walks right up the stairs and goes
and gets the 38 special and comes down
she takes the tactical position
right by the door waits okay doesn't go
out and
you know doesn't leave the tactical
advantage of the home like we talked
about in class you know
it doesn't leave the tactical advantage
of the home to go you know control
the threat okay she waits and she was
like and
you know mom's crying okay and she
is how old 17 17 and she like she's
trained for this
yeah she's learned from us right and she
uh
she looks at her mom and she's like i'm
just i'm just telling you mom
if he comes through the door i'm gonna
shoot him and you need to be ready for
that
okay it never happened he couldn't he
couldn't figure his way into the garage
took about 15 minutes he leaves okay
the cops show up an hour and a half
later there you go
okay and they make a statement and then
you know
and so she's you know a.g comes to
brunch with us like a few days later and
she's she's telling
she's telling us this and she said it
and you know as out of a 17 year old's
mouth she was like dad
i'm so glad that you taught me how to do
that because
i was scared but i knew what to do okay
and that's the thing so you you have a
you have a 17 year old that came that
close
to having to do what we never imagined
we would ever have to do
what do you think about having a license
to carry adam i mean you know in
nightclubs miami
you know you're selling insurance
policies life settlements bring a gun
into a club that's for sure okay
uh something that comes to mind we had
the gentleman come i i
escaped his name he did an interview uh
former secret service
fbi agent clinton oh no no no no no
okay yes yes yes what's his name again
his last name craig craig craig schaefer
stud
and he said there's what eight billion
people on this planet how many billion
people on this planet
seven point eight okay pat knows
he said 95 of people are good
decent normal great people
five percent of people are just straight
up lunatics
psychos homicidal maniacs will kill you
so you're thinking oh ninety-five
percent of people is great right it's
awesome
five percent okay that's not so much pat
i know you're a math wizard what's five
percent of seven point eight billion
small number three point three three
point five million five percent three
point seven eight
three point eight million okay million
yeah so basically
essentially how many people are in
america 328. okay so basically that's
the
equivalent of the united states and
canada that are straight-up maniacs out
there
that's a great statistic okay so there
you go feel free to use that
so extrapolate that all over all over
the world so
yeah but that's what that's what i tell
my students though this is what i tell
my students and it's mind-boggling
because
when i say it it's like a light goes off
in their head i say look
there's no safe places yeah there's only
safe people
and one person can come and change the
dynamic of an environment immediately
and the environment is changed for the
duration of their time in that
environment yeah
so i got a question for you i got to
quit last night i pulled up a bunch of
stats about guns
okay because i want to know stats about
guns what percentage of
gun ownership in the world do you think
is in the u.s
all the guns in the world what
percentage you think is u.s
very high give me another you want to
give us a multiple choice or you want us
just to guess no i just want you to
guess so imagine out of all the gun
owners in the world
okay at least half there is 857 million
gun owners in the world
what percentage is u.s a quarter okay
you're saying quarter what do you think
it is
i'm curious louise out of all the
registered gun owners what percentage is
you us
let's say 15 i'm gonna go lower twenty
percent twenty percent what are you
gonna say
thirty percent kai i'm a quarter you
said 50 you said half
stick to it well okay sure 46 she wins
okay
46 of gun owners in the world
are in the u.s think about it okay think
about that that's a big number but
40 does that count multiple guns like we
know people that have 50 guns in there
no no no no this is just you're a gun
owner
you're one okay it doesn't matter how
many you own yeah you own at least one
right
46 i'm sorry 46 of uh civilian guns
owned
okay you're right multiple guns guns oh
we have some people in the middle right
that have
now watch dozen guns in there watch this
who do you think is number two country
who do you think is number two countries
australia you will never guess number
two country
and we know it's not venezuela okay
sound as well it's not australia
if you're listening to this who do you
think is the number two
country that has the most guns
owned number two switzerland no india
india's number two sweden india how i
would have never guessed india of course
what do you mean there's a billion
people there and it's a democracy you
did the math is what you did but
71.1 bill 1 million guns
are registered on you know in india yeah
71.1 now watch what happens here okay
then i went in and and i looked at
different stats okay
uh on gun ownership statistic okay 42 of
households
uh own a gun in america 42 percent of
that's a big number by the way 42 30 of
individuals own a gun that means three
out of ten so in this room two four
six out of six two of us own guns do you
own one do you own one
do you own one louise your whole family
has gone but he doesn't though
he doesn't two of us do that makes about
sense i have enough for all of you
yeah there's plenty in that safe someone
comes in here to valuetainment
47 of male men own a gun
only 13 women 47
to 13 one think about it who actually
needs it
who doesn't need it it's the other way
around of ownership my good buddy sean
lowry
shout out to him he says what's number
three what's number three i i i only
have top two right now i don't know okay
sean dude's a favorite i do gold and
silver i don't go bronze but he wants to
go proud
sean lowry find that outfit like sweden
i think it's probably sweden so
why sweden so watch this i think either
sweden or switzerland that makes you do
like be in the military are guns like a
thing in norway is that allowed is it a
guys these stats are about to get more
interesting this is i'm getting to a
question here okay
watch these stats check this out let's
go down to the gun
so we have male 47 female 13 percent
white 33 percent non-white me
18 okay you're considered white just so
you know that
me not me come on man republicans
surprisingly
41 yeah democrats 23 percent
if there was a fight between if a civil
war broke let's not even go
there let's not even go there let's
olive branch independent
27 percent good by the way uh actually
republicans have nearly twice as much
guns they own as democrats shout out to
my republican friends out there buddy
i'm on your side when we're going down
to a war now come on now okay so now
here's here's some other stats
civilians defend themselves with a gun
an estimated
990 000 times a year civilians
defend themselves with a gun an
estimated
990 thousand times it's a lot of times
by the way a million times a year yes
exactly americans use guns to frighten
away intruders
498 thousand times you coming to my
house cha-cha
okay oh [ __ ] something's going to go
down if i want to cheer up exactly and
that crazy baghdad
40 of felons decided not to commit crime
because they knew or believed the victim
was carrying a gun that's a very
going back to what she was talking about
40 but we're about to get to a question
here that kind of threw me off a little
bit i got two stats i'm going to bring
up i want to ask your thoughts on this
and obviously our expert gunman here uh
adam
27 years you know he's been watching
people with guns but never owned it
but educational level of gun owners you
ready education
gun education level of gun owners this
is a very weird stat kai
and i'm cur i have my own uh assumptions
why this is but i want to hear your
thoughts
college post graduates is the lowest
percentage of gun owners
30 percent so if you got an mba it's the
lowest percentage of gun owners
yeah then it's college graduates 37
some college 41 high school grad or less
42 so the more the education the less
gun ownership the less they're
saying exactly let's have that i want to
have because i knew you were going to
love this with your peers on your
community
so educated people so if you have an mba
on the wall
there's a chance there's a lower chance
of you having a gun than a person
that barely has a high school diploma
why is that
i think that's just part of culture
right the united
you're working as stand white-collar
business
you're probably the less likely you're
going to be using a gun i don't know
jared i think that it's because you feel
safer where you are
because you're you're educated you're
probably typically making more money you
probably feel like you live in a
safe place okay okay or you have
gated security or you have you're living
in a good community
you're living in more money you can
afford a uh
a butler with a gun just because you can
afford a battery
but where are you living in the batcave
all my butler's got guns guys come on
okay alfred you know
let's go so so why else though why else
do people would degree i would love to
hear your opinion on this you get an
angle on this so i don't want to step on
the pbd's track
i'm asking you guys i'm just giving i'm
just i think it's part of the culture
and i i don't want to like um stereotype
but
you know um you know the first thing oh
i think that's a sign that i'm just not
gonna jared why don't you take a
comparison i'll say
i'll give you a couple thoughts i'll
give you a couple thoughts when when
adam gets nervous
his seat drops it just reads him well i
just realized that jarrah has a gun
and i'm trying to come back are you
right now yeah yes you are
that's right yes she is right now she's
jared i apologize for anything i may or
may not have said already
yeah sure our audience you know i can
only can imagine like uh uh
if a soy boy were to date a jarrah if a
soy boy would have dated
now soy boy is what a guy who is that
was actually going to be my next
question
what is the soy boy so i found that i
found that out
so a soy boy is the champion
by the way i would love to see who
actually came up with that nickname
for who came up with that nickname i
think it was a girl that was like
somebody said soyboy is a uh uh
pejorative term
often used in online communities to
describe men perceived as lacking
masculine characteristics
the term bears many similarities there's
many has been compared to the slang term
of uh
how do you pronounce that cuck yeah cuck
another term popularly used as an insult
for male femininity
yeah by online communities soyboy i
don't know if you're a soy boy
but if a soy boy were to date a i'm not
a soy boy but i play one on a podcast
yeah but
you're definitely not a soy boy if one
of the stats said a sword boy is a guy
who marries his first girlfriend that's
definitely not going to be you because
you've been on there 201 he's still not
married so
if a soy boy would a date a jarrah
yeah and they're at a bar yeah and a guy
comes and talks smack to the soy boy
what's the soda boy going to say i swear
to god you say one more thing jared's
going to work here
you say one more thing one more you want
to have a say one more thing right now
she's gonna put you in there i feel like
you know if a soy boy ends up with
jarrah and they say you may kiss the
bride
jarrah's gonna pick me up and like walk
me out
i'm gonna like take you over the
threshold is that what we're doing with
this
oh my god but let me give you my theory
why i think
the more you know i've never dated a
girl like jarrah every girl i've ever
dated
are you not me hitting on you are you
scared every girl i've ever dated has
been like more of like a feminine you
know like a feminine
model type you know that's where you're
going with your language right our
feminist is going to come after you
we've got a big feminist community
great i enjoy welcome to the party y'all
but i've never dated a girl that's like
all right buddy i got this from here so
boy you know it's
not that you talk like that you're very
feminine yourself really not that you're
not feminine
the only track down the moment you went
there
you couldn't come back you're committed
i just
is because i'm less likely to be
convicted by a jury
okay i don't know what that means but
yeah why are you less likely to be
a woman okay i'm a woman that defended
myself with a firearm so
you know statistically i'm i'm probably
less likely to be convicted by a jury so
you should use that to your full
advantage what type of guys do you
typically date jared you said you're
single
no no she's got a boyfriend no i do you
have a boyfriend okay cool tell us tell
us about your boyfriend
he's a big he's a very large person he's
a big dude yes how big is big
he's about six five probably 240 250.
and are you more like i want a manly
big burly you know gun caring kind of
guy
we met at the gun range
i mean so it's not gonna happen at your
comedy
club 99 of the girls i've dated have
been in a club and live club live in
south beach like
she's meeting dudes at a gun range kai
meets girls at the library
sam meets girls at the salsa club
self-made yoga lounge
yoga place it goes to it's the self uh
what do you call it
do it yourself yoga yeah yeah it's a
nice one so is that typically the kind
of guys you date
like the bigger gun rangy type of guys
no i mean i dated an entrepreneur before
that i mean who
you know i mean he was a he was a gun
owner but it's not like he you know
went all the time um you know i just i
don't know that i have a type
honestly would you ever date a guy that
does not own a gun
that would be tough straight up it's
like that's like
you know let me check the boxes here all
right cool good looking
you know makes money funny doesn't own a
gun get this guy by the way you know
you're making people uncomfortable yeah
i dated a comedian from new york one
time and
that was that was interesting and he he
wasn't really super like pro-gun
so he wasn't no so i can only imagine
how that date goes
so very you give a hug and after you
give her a hug you feel something very
you know hard over here and it's a gun
you're like wait a minute what is that
all about oh it's my gun
yeah do you have better than whatever
the alternative would be
please tell me that's a gun well that's
happened before as well but but anyways
let me go back to the theory let me go
back to the theory here on why
the percentage is yeah sorry our
audience does not want me asking jarrah
questions our audience is
very offended that i would uh delve into
her personal life are you okay
talking about your personality i mean
well i mean i'm armed okay you're good
yeah all right you know what for our
audience i love you guys
i'm being so sensitive is getting
knocked out listen we're good guys
take a lesson from me you take punches
you keep coming back okay so
so so let's let's go back to this my
theory on these stats okay so more
the more the education yeah let's get
back to that the less the gun ownership
i think
absolutely i agree the fact that the
more income you make the more money you
make you're gonna live in a better
community so obviously you're not going
to have a need for guns
okay that totally makes sense to me but
what also makes sense to me is
how long does it take does it take to
get an mba what's the timeline of
getting an nba kai
give me a timeline six to eight years is
that about a good timeline
you mean when you start college from the
day you're 18 years old you go to
college to get in your mba how long is
it yeah six to eight years
i mean okay yeah is it fair to say that
the people who are instructors in school
that we call them professors that they
probably don't like guns
100 yes and i know where you're going
they tend to be more liberal
one out of 10 professors in school are
conservative 9 out of 10
are liberal this is a statistic you can
see from washington post
this isn't something new so i don't know
how many times a professor is going to
say
i drove to school today and i had a gun
on me and i left it in the car or it's
just not going to happen so the people
that are also
most people the people they're spending
most time with they're not
you know pro secondary they're not
saying hey let me go by you should
buy a gun to protect yourself so i think
it's also having to do with
who you're around a lot to have a lot of
influence on you not owning a gun i
think there's a part of it that's also
being influenced by the system that they
have because for it to be
41 42 to 31
high school degree you barely graduated
high school 41 42
own a gun mba it's 30 31
there is influence going on is there a
correlation between
um education and guns just from a brain
capacity that's the other side because
also brain capacity i'll give you the
other side as well the other side as
well is
atheists atheists okay or agnostics or
those that don't believe in god
the more degrees they get many of them
that end up saying i just don't believe
in a god
right they typically are the ones that
are more you know they've had more
degrees so
what is that is it because they've been
able to figure it out for themselves and
they're a little less naive
is it because their surroundings is it
because the universities and colleges
don't pray anymore what is it so there's
a there's a
two ways you can look at this with
influence but uh anyways
how about we go to the brianna taylor uh
officer yesterday you heard about the
riots you heard about the protesting
there's a part of it you were dealing
with last night a little bit having to
do with that in
in dallas that you were telling me about
earlier uh
there's a lot of things going on right
now i'll just kind of read some of his
stuff here right now and i want to turn
it over to you guys to kind of tell me
what your thoughts are
with the brianna taylor uh officer
charts officer brett hankins
hankinson who was fired in june was
indicted on three counts of wanton
endangerment which uh wanton
endangerment
means blindly shooting without knowing
what you're shooting at you know
we'll get into that here in a second so
three counts on wanton endangerment the
first degree jefferson county grand jury
decided wednesday neither the grand jury
nor the presiding judge elaborated on
the charges
authorities found that the bullets fired
by hackies henkeson
traveled into the neighboring apartment
while three residents were home
a male a pregnant female and a child
attorney general daniel cameron said at
a press conference after the grand
jury's announcement
hankinson was not charging taylor's
death but rather for engaging in
endangering her neighbors lives now
obviously that's
that's just that's gonna create a frenzy
right there with hankinson not being
charged for taylor's death rather for
endangering
her neighbors lives a warrant was issued
for his
arrest and he was booked and released on
fifteen thousand dollars bill
according to local reports despite
executing a no knockout warrant
cameron cameron's office said that the
officer did announce themselves before
busting door
busting down the door of the apartment
occupied
by taylor and her boyfriend kenneth
walker you know i i spent a lot of time
watching a lot of videos on this topic i
read a lot of articles new york times is
a great article apart one part two
i read washington post i read anything
on the left or right the middle anything
i can but i want to hear your
perspective
you're in this world you've been
following the story very closely
what are your thoughts about what's
happening right now with this case
i think that the the information the
communication
uh has been grossly mishandled
in this um you know we're saying you
know we're seeing you know right now
that
they're they're saying yeah well it was
a no-knock warrant but we did
you know announce ourselves this is the
first that we're hearing of it
yeah um i even i read an article um you
know
at 6 15 this morning um that said that
there was some sort of independent
witness
that can corroborate this this is the
first that we're hearing of any of it
and when you when you don't communicate
effectively with the the general public
all you do is galvanize them all you do
is is you know
let them think the worst okay and so now
you know we have a situation where you
know this is just
one more just sort of you know
notch in in the belt of of the general
community not trusting law enforcement
anymore
because you got you know it's like you
people can't communicate
with with us you can't tell us the truth
you can't give us information
i understand when you're doing an
investigation there's only so much
you know that you can give out but i
don't see how
telling us two months ago
that you announced yourself even though
it was a no knock warrant and you have a
witness that can corroborate that
how's that going to hurt anything right
i mean that that gives us a little bit
of
you know if that was the case you know
that may have fundamentally changed
things
but because now you're you're not going
to indict
uh or or you're not i'm sorry you're not
going to you know move forward with
charges
and now you're releasing all this new
information or this old information
that's new to us
i think that's super irresponsible on
the part of the of the police department
wow i think that's super super
irresponsible and i think that
uh you know that that girl was
innocent uh for for all we know i mean
of with all the information that we that
we've been given
uh you know she was innocent um that was
a huge
tragedy and i think that something needs
to be done about it
i think she has probably the most unique
voice
on this story being that she works side
by side with law enforcement right i
mean you're
you're considering i mean i just pulled
guns out last night
right okay okay she she's a gun
instructor
yeah female yep has lived alone
yeah um has lived with the boyfriend
sure um
owns guns has dealt with police um
you have a very unique situation a story
on this you know i'm
look this the word that comes to mind is
optics like what like you hear this you
hear
misinformation like you said you read
there's so much going on here like
last week we covered the fact that her
family was awarded
12 million dollars right by the city of
louisville yep
okay people have been talking about um
viewed as a settlement you know because
that's blue as a you know maybe that's
not why for sure um you know then this
word comes out uh
wanton endangerment yeah wanton
endangerment what is wanton endangerment
you have you have a dead female
the boyfriend was arrested he's then
since been released i googled what
wanton endangerment is i never heard
that
it's substantial danger of death or
injury to another person
an extreme indifference to the value of
human life
reckless endangerment so that's what the
officer
hankinson was charged with and that's
another but that's another and i don't
mean to direct you but that's another
lack of communication
is like you come out and say this is
what this person's being charged with
but you don't explain you know what it
is and so if you're if you're in texas
if you're watching the show in texas
that's the equivalent to penal code 9.05
in texas which is reckless injury or
death of an innocent third party and
here's the craziest part of that okay
this wanton endangerment the charges
were not even
because of miss taylor's death right it
was because
of the neighbors that were almost shot
by the police officers so like if you're
on one side of this you're like what the
hell is going on here
so what comes to mind when i see all
these riots
and protests that are obviously people
are outraged about this
so um pat what year did you come to
america
uh november 28 1990. november 20th
two years before rodney king boom that's
where i was going with that so you were
here for a few years
rodney king if you guys don't remember
rodney king he was a black man
pulled over the side of the road and
argument ensues with four police
officers was on pcp
okay yeah all right sure but basically
they end up beating the
living crap out of this guy to um
for near-death experience recorded
recorded pre-cell phone
cell phone this is people i mean can you
imagine how many things like this
happened
before cell phone and camera time yep
but they filmed these guys
beating the crap out of him with batons
batons batons
fast forward what happens to these four
police officers
nothing nothing happens they get they
walk off
and what happens in la you were there
for two years what do you mean nothing
happens
so they don't charge with anything they
they could they go back to their jobs
i don't i'm not sure what happened with
that no that's not where i'm going okay
okay
that's not where i'm going with this
point is they didn't get in deep
trouble yeah okay i'm sure a couple of
them lost their jobs riots protesting
that's where i'm going
okay okay so the city of l.a
this is when tupac was running the show
in l.a yeah he famously said we'll burn
this mother
down did he not yeah and you were just
living in l.a for the first time
so i'm thinking and i was on his side at
that time just you were on tupac's side
at that time
you were what we're willing to burn la
down i was i was
on the side against anything to do with
cops
government anything this is a 14 year
old 13 year old path that's just kind of
like
clueless about what's going on with life
pre-republican pat
not republican independent
pre-independent the difference between
me and you is i have voted on both sides
okay that's the difference between me
and you right you only voted on one side
that's not true for presidential i've
only voted
once that's the biggest level but i've
also voted for republicans on what
in the senate for governor the the
property mayor level like with six days
that's the republican units
yeah of course my my property manager
was a republican i've written
is that kind of where francis suarez is
republican city of miami
can you order a box of cookies from the
local cookie store for this buddy here
here's my point tell your point we've
been waiting for you you're you're
famous
we're gonna get pat a t-shirt that says
what's your point that's gonna 100 we
got a good one as well miami
shout out to them for one shout out go
ahead we just cracked two thousand
viewers thank you two thousand
people live listening are wondering what
is adam's next
here's my point the last thing that we
want to see in america
are cities being burnt down the last
thing we want to see
are right okay can we all agree upon yes
okay
so sometimes you have to reverse
engineer what you're doing
so if you're the city of louisville in
this case
and we say all right guys we are up to
our eyeballs and some [ __ ] right
here if we know if we come out with this
wanton endangerment no charges against
the police we know what's going to
happen not only in louisville not only
in kentucky
all over america so when we make this
decision
let's prepare for the worst case
scenario i'm not sure they did that
because number one let's just back up
two police officers were shot yesterday
i hope they are doing okay like that's
the last thing that we want in america
today
but when you make this type of decision
and you charge one officer with wanton
endangerment which is like a slap on the
wrist
just expect the worst case scenario and
that's the last thing we want to see
here
he probably should have been charged
with wanting endangerment anyway
right on top of i think maybe one or two
other things what do you think he should
have been charged with or any of these
police officers should have been charged
with in your i think at minimum he
should have been charged with
involuntary manslaughter
okay um because you can't
now here's the thing though it's it's
when we start critiquing the police
we have to remember that you are not the
police
you've never been the police have you
ever have you ever had to
clear an apartment for squatters have
you ever had to serve a no knock warrant
or a warrant in general
have you ever you know huh at best two
cats because he's got cats yeah two cats
gotcha okay very intense listen cats can
flip the switch on you real quick yeah
okay let's not very well behave but
continue with the police please joe you
know
they i you know i have worked side by
side with the police i have had to clear
uh you know apartments i've had to you
know i've kind of been taken by surprise
a couple of times and i can i can see it
from both sides um but what i'm but i
what i will say
is that there's a stark difference
there's a huge
delta between justice and revenge
okay and there's i think that what the
the protest community not maybe not the
protest community but the riot community
wants blood they want revenge and that's
where that's where it's coming
and so you have to know that when you're
making the decision
yeah exactly and i work
overnight in the exact same communities
that are experiencing what's happening
to brianna taylor
and so we have to be you know now i
think policing
personally is more about
sympathy empathy and leadership
than it is about authority and i think
that that's what the policing
that's what the policing needs to get
back to but you have to understand that
absolute power corrupts absolutely
and so when you put somebody uh in a
position of authority like that
with a gun power to a rest whether
they've seen it or not so like as a
personal protection officer
i can only arrest somebody if they
commit a felony in my purview
i can't go find somebody that because
somebody said
okay it has to happen in front of me
and i think that when you
give a lot of power to you know in a lot
of authority to the police
and sometimes they need it right okay
but in generalities
that gets in your head i know
because i have to remind myself all the
time
when i go out and work in these
communities that
these people are my brothers and sisters
they're in in humanity okay i have to
remember that civilians
civilians no matter the what no matter
what lifestyle they lead
no matter where they live no matter what
they've done
okay i have to i have to understand that
the only thing
that i have that i get to judge is what
they're doing right now
so it's like when people say well george
floyd did
he you know he held a gun to a pregnant
lady's belly and he was high on this and
he did that
that's not that's not for you okay
now do we do i think he needs to be
glorified on on the back of an nfl
helmet hell no
but what he did before
doesn't matter at that moment what
matters
is that i couldn't agree with you more
on that topic but i will tell you a
couple things here i i got a couple
different uh
perspectives on this here so so one is
we got three people involved in this
situation right we got brianna taylor
okay then you have kenneth walker who is
the boyfriend she's currently with then
you have jamarcus glover
there's three people the ex-boyfriend so
when you sit there and you think about
her choice of picking men
she needs to read the right books on
picking the right boyfriend
because the history of the boyfriend so
she started off 2020 saying have a new
job new courier knew this she was
expecting 2020 to be a big year
she blocked her ex-boyfriend on
instagram
social didn't want to deal with it and
in the middle of the night at 12 30 when
the cops came insane were entering the
current boyfriend thought it was the x
coming in so he shoots and as a cop
you know you got your team you got to
make sure you're protecting they didn't
shoot first he fired first
and then they shot now obviously they
shot brianna taylor which is tragic
for that to be taking place they they're
held accountable for that that's the 12
million
lawsuit that's been paid and the the
hankinson guy
he had issues in the past already it's
not like this was his first term he
couldn't control his temper and
i put that uh onus on the department not
being able to see
when i see a switch of power like i
watch my guys i run a sales company
i watch which one of my guys becomes
power hungry
it's very dangerous when that happens
because in a sales organization what do
you do
you're the greatest you're so amazing
phenomenal talk you're so special i'm so
proud of you
it's so much of building people up that
unfortunately some people
have no clue how to take that some
people take it and they start thinking
they're what they're gonna the man i can
do whatever yeah
there's no humility there's no humility
humility goes away you can't tell me
what to do do you realize who i am
so cops go in intention original
intention is what
i want to serve i want to make a
difference right and sometimes when all
of a sudden you go to a club i got a gun
you kind of start seeing people looking
at you differently you kind of go a
little bit like this little like
and if there is a any sense of character
issue on the inside with insecurities
you got a problem with that cop so i
think the testing needs to change
people need to have the one thing we
constantly are trying to get better at
is hiring better
every time i fire somebody after i hire
them in four four to eight weeks and it
doesn't work out
i always take full responsibility i
always say because i'm like why didn't
you hire better
you should have known this wasn't gonna
work out why don't you ask those
additional nine questions
it's not the guy's fault it's your fault
you should have hired better
you can sit there and point at people as
much as you want this cost me money that
guy cost me six thousand dollars this
guy cost me
you should have never hired a guy in the
first place you take the ownership i
have to take the ownership because i'm
the one to blame
to not have asked the right questions
because maybe this wasn't a cultural fit
so when we're sitting there we're going
after hiring after hiring after hiring
so number one i think the department
needs to
get a better predictive analytics
questions they ask to hire people that
has to do with the eyes are important
yeah that has to do with ego and
insecurities
it's very very difficult to give
somebody who's very insecure a lot of
power
it's very dangerous so so that's one
part so this guy hankinson
you know he first of all he's got
problems he's had problems his resume
doesn't look good anyways
so we can go one by one by one then we
look at brianna taylor
if brianna taylor's my daughter 26 year
old okay you got brianna taylor
emt she's trying to be a nurse she's
involved in a conversation about 14
thousand dollars let me go do this and
she's given the car
that she gets to the friend of jo you
know of kenneth and
what are you doing being involved in
these types of situations so sometimes i
remember one night
i never forget this i come out of the
military my friend picks me up
and this is a friend that i was good
friends with regular guy
very good guy was you know guy that i
hung out with all the time
and he picks me up in his car and we go
out to hollywood
we have a great time he says let me tell
you who i am now i said who are you now
he opens the trunk
when he opens the trunk the trunk is
filled this is in 97.
it's filled filled with pot
he's got vicodin pills he's got coke
whatever you want to buy he's got it all
now this is not what he did prior to me
joining the military i come in he goes
from being a 3.5 4.0 gpa
to now one of these guys he's got all
this stuff in the back of his truck
right
so i'm sitting there and an event takes
place that has to do with cops and all
this other stuff i'm sitting there all
i'm thinking about
is if he gets arrested tonight i'm in
the military i'm going to military jail
if i go to military prison i can't get
my securities license if i can get my
securities license
i can't work for morgan stanley dean but
if i don't go to morgan stanley dinwidd
i don't give my series if i don't get my
series seven
i'm probably not getting into insurance
if i don't get into insurance i don't
know what i'm doing today
i may be selling a gym membership were
you thinking you're your next fighter i
went right there in my mind i'm like if
i get arrested today i go to military
prison
but who taught you how to think like
that but but uh well that's mom and dad
that's parenting parenting they told you
that
think about your my mom always people in
these communities
i agree with you and and again going
back to i agree with you but what i'm
trying to say is
it but if she has enough thinking to go
to emt she's trying to be a nurse she's
doing all this other stuff so
look something like one night i got
arrested in la
okay and i got arrested because i was
accused of being from ms-13 and i'm not
ms-13 i'm middle eastern
i'm not mara savatrucha so i got
mistaken for ms-13
and they came they arrested me i got
it's me and my two buddies and one of my
friends has a big scar going here that
he fell from a park and he broke his
and there you know i'm like dude the
guy's not in wooties teasing were like
he's a gangster but i'm not a gangster
he was like all freaking out
that on the pizza shop but you were
arrested i got arrested helicopters all
this stuff i'm on my
chevy s10 low profile you know gold 145
spokes it's real
nice i'm i j i barely turned 16.
because i'm i'm my birthday's a month
off from when i was born we came to the
states yeah one month off
anyways we got arrested so i'm like what
are we doing getting arrested today
and i'm like you know the situation here
is
okay you bought a car from a guy that
was an ms-13 guy
you knew this guy was a leader you
didn't get your car registered quickly
you kind of drove with his registration
okay i mean this makes sense why this is
taking place they understood they let me
go it's good to go
what's the moral of the story look
you're gonna be guilty by association if
you hang out with the wrong crowd so
the messaging goes to a few different
people because i sit there and every
event that takes place i want to take
things away we made some comments about
the louisville
deal the other day 12 million dollars
and we kind of skimmed through it
quickly and i got a
long message from somebody that i
respect and said i think you need to go
a little bit deeper on this topic
because i think you guys kind of went
through this topic like as if it was a
business topic i said fair enough
i'll respect what you're saying because
i respect who this individual is
so number one association what can
our kids take away from this if your
kids are listening to this right now 20
years from now
what do you want them to take away from
this buddy choose who you're hanging
around with
every time i got in trouble it was bad
association every time i wasn't
just in a bad crowd doing something
stupid we know when we're around a bad
crowd
and the onus is on us we can't say mom
dad we can
like you said something earlier that was
so powerful when you were a teenager a
tragic event happened to you
your mom and dad couldn't have protected
you that day you said there's only one
person that could have protected you
it's you and i i didn't think about it
that way and no wonder you won't have a
license to carry because if somebody
happens and the cops doesn't show for
three minutes
you have a way to protect yourself the
moment you become 18 years old you have
to make the decisions
and some of the decisions you're going
to make are going to be good or bad now
let me go to the other part
the other part with this situation that
you look at is influencers
hollywood and celebrities okay let me
kind of take this
the day jesse smallett came out and he
told the story
do you remember how everybody reacted
that day
everyone was feeling juicy smoothie if
they were like i totally
he came out everybody defended who how
could this happen no way juicy is mullet
this is why
racism protests america's a racist
nation
the moment yeah he got caught did
those same celebrities retract their
statements
none of them right very little the only
person that stayed quiet was who
chappelle because if this just doesn't
sound right you mean two africans in the
middle of the night are going to come in
they're telling me
two african guys in mega hats in chicago
dude
she's a brilliant dude so so you go to
this and you say where is this to
playing with hollywood and athletes and
celebrities
do you really want to unite america do
you really
do you really want to you know is it is
it the smarter thing to tell
players and hollywood people to say
folks
i cannot believe what happened to
brianna but we have to wait and get the
information
why do you jump to conclusion so when
you jump to conclusion
what do you do it's kind of like this
it's like assuming
you you you your girl let's just say
your girl
uh is you know somebody sent something
about your girl
and you come to the pal let me tell you
what's going on i'm like
bro how do you know i'm just telling you
and you have no proof
nothing nowhere like it's not like you
have pictures or anything or anything
joke
you have no proof so imagine i'm not
next dude i told you she's a freaking
[ __ ] you know
i told you this is why so when a guy is
married
one of his divorced friends or single
friends a lot of single friends want to
make you be single because you want to
go party together
married people want to get people to be
married right okay so somebody
oh my gosh you shouldn't do this you
should leave you should go
no rather the answer should be what bro
i don't know
i haven't heard what's what's so there
is an element of that
taking place here where we jump to
conclusion very quickly then i'll give
you the last one here and i'll turn it
over to you guys to see what you think
and we can change topics
because we've been going on guns for a
while and probably some of the people
are gunned out
and we can go talk about business next
here's the last one
you know who gets a lot of credit and
who i believe is going to make this
the world a better place when it comes
down to crime steve jobs
steve jobs absolutely steve jobs you
know why steve jobs
can i answer that yes cameras cameras
cameras respectively jobs because
citizens tim apple journalism you know
somebody that now is can go around
recording videos
now we can see eight minutes and 46
seconds you had your knee on george
floyd what are you doing
now we can see where no no no as long as
it's not edited to what they want you to
see as
if it's live it's not edited if it's
live it's not edited right it's also
cameras that the cops wear i i love i
love accountability
i love all of that stuff but at the same
time you know when when military folks
came back from
vietnam and and they were at hotels
people were spitting on them and all the
stuff they were doing to
military folks you have no idea what
these guys went to yeah you think these
guys woke up in the morning saying i
want to go to war no these guys are
serving their military trying to bring
freedom to you but everybody jump to
conclusion because military you know the
media would say these military guys are
warmongers all this other stuff
we also don't know what good cops go
through throughout the day
you know for every one bad story you
tell here about what a cop did
then when's the last time you watch cnn
or msnbc
or abc or any of the when is actually
the last time
you saw them share stories of what cops
do right
when's the last time yeah i i will say
that you i don't see stupid do you see
some stories i'm not saying
it's tell me one but it's not saying
it's cnn or tell me what i'm going to
tell you some stories
on cnn and nbc that's specifically who
i'm asking for you see
you do see stories of during the protest
this is when
after george floyd that i'll give you a
story in fort lauderdale there was an
argument over a cop he pushed some guy
social you you again i don't know where
this was exactly but you do
see yes cops coming up social because of
steve jobs okay
on social there's a big difference but
you do see stories of course
i shared a video with a guy on my
instagram profile this guy's like what
are you doing
why are you coming out here you did that
i did that i'm 28 you're 41. what are
you doing now my five-year-old son is
going to do this one day why are we
doing this to ourselves
and i the guy's crying saying this to a
group of people i share this
media's not going to share that kind of
stuff do you ever watch uh
see not cnn but cnn headline news with
robin mead
do you know who that is okay so there's
two cnns there's cnn
the main channel and then kind of like
just the fact that no one knows who
robert robin
is the way you the way you should i'm
not saying she's huge or she's not huge
she said uh uh pull up robin me if i say
right now do you know who rachel meadows
what would you say
i do do you know what anderson cooper is
of course do you know who morning joey
mead is a very famous person
do you guarantee you this do you know
she says good morning sunshine every
morning she's famous she's beautiful
she has her own show on cnn headline
news all she does is give good news of
the day and all i'm saying is
there are good news stories out there so
do you tell me
that people the main anchors on cnn and
msnbc are reporting good things cops are
saying
this lady right here you have one
example unfortunately she's not the main
faceless wondering if
i'm you know i'm wondering if the media
isn't what we need to define
you know what i mean i'm wondering well
the media is divisive
so i have a i have a good friend named
maj who runs a
an organization called black guns matter
and uh his kind of yeah
his stick is you know media is the most
effective devil
in america
uh i got you see so
it's uh you know in into your point
you know about you know about that is
you know that that's a huge part of
what's
you know galvanizing you know these
riots and
i always tell my students if you see a
video on social media
don't comment on it wait four days wait
three new cycles
yeah something else is gonna come out
that's gonna that could potentially make
you think differently
that's that's a basic thing that i don't
think we're doing
enough of where we're not waiting to see
what is really taking place we're just
jumping a conclusion and just kind of
going out there and
these influencers are doing more of it
and they don't realize that their fans
are young
kids fans of sports are how old they're
not older people
young fans of you know athletes are
younger people like one day i want to be
like this guy one day i want to be like
that guy
you're not uniting america you're
dividing america and it's disappointing
to see that yeah
they're going to do what you do because
they equate what you're doing with
success
they're actually not going to do what
you do because what you do the athlete
is gonna go to their seven million
dollar home what the other person is
doing is going to their one bedroom
apartment living with four people and
they're gonna go do what you're not
willing to do meaning
the athlete is gonna tell them go out
there protest but the athletes not going
out there protesting the athletes
putting the responsibility on the 18
year old kid not thinking that someone's
child
and they don't think about the severity
of what could happen to someone's kid
this kid grew up in a family
i i was living with my mother my mom was
a single mother raising us and i saw my
dad twice a month
i didn't have a day-to-day father figure
my mom couldn't control me at 14 years
old
my mom hit me one time and i was looking
as a mom what are you doing
she hit me one time and she held her arm
i said you gotta stop hitting man
you realize it doesn't hurt anymore like
you got to stop and that was the last
time she hit me
i was six one at 14 years old what are
you gonna tell me to do i'm like dude
just stop
so from that moment you couldn't control
this kid what if
one of my people i looked up to a jordan
said you better go out there and do this
this is not fair
i probably would have been capable of
doing something stupid and i wouldn't
been able to do what i've done with my
life now
you know you look at a story you think
oh my gosh this person was destined
[ __ ]
[ __ ] sometimes somebody else could
have influenced that person to ruin
their lives
these athletes and hollywood celebrities
i love sports more than words can
describe
i'm a stat guy i love baseball i love
football i love basketball
i love anything to do with competition
but they got to stop dividing they're
not doing a uh
that was a really powerful point and i
don't think i've ever thought of it that
way
yeah let me say one thing to build upon
your story about who you were hanging
out with
in la and when you got arrested and this
is something that i gravitate to and i
tell people all the time
your network is your net worth right
show me the
five people you're hanging out with the
most i'll show you your future
and you had to make a realization that
whoever you were hanging out with when
you were 14 you were 16
were probably not the people you were
gonna they're going to get you to the
next level would you agree
100 okay yeah so your net worth at that
time was not
the equivalent of where your net worth
could have been but i went down the
wrong
i agree with you and i tell you there
was there was a bit of luck it's very
easy for us to kind of tooth our horn
and say oh let me tell you it's because
of this
no like i got kids now man i'm not like
what she said i totally agree with her
today's my son's birthday it's dylan's
birthday's birthday
you know dylan dylan's a athlete he's
got calves bigger than his daddy's he's
got the perfect bubble butt of my you
know
bo jackson and he's just he's just you
know such a
every kid has got a different kind of a
soul about themselves he said i'm laying
this kid down and i'm playing with his
hair and i'm just looking at him he's
knocked out
and i'm just like listen you know god i
i
so desperately need you to watch over my
kids
because i'm not around all the time
there's only so much i can do as their
dad i'd love to protect them 24 7. i
can't
do it you need someone to watch over
them
we have to understand that every brianna
is someone's daughter man
this is someone's daughter this this is
someone's family this is someone's blood
you know
blood is painful when something happens
to them and there comes a time that you
either have to count on the man upstairs
to protect your kids
you have to count on the values and
principles you pass to the kids or you
have to count on the fact that the
people they look up to
set a good example that they're worth
modeling you have to you have to be
relying on that anyways
let's shift well if you're a god-fearing
person you need to understand the
christian principles of self-defense
but that might be for another podcast
i'm writing a book about it though all
right
wow there you go do you have a title of
the book yet the christian principles of
self-defense wow
there we go anyway shout out to dylan
bet david
turning yeah seven six years dylan is
seven today man he's seven
today comment happy birthday to dylan
beth david
kidd boy thank you our friends like and
give a thumbs up
to our audience we just cracked 2.2 i
love it dylan's
birthday he's the best so let's let's
talk about something a little more uh
you know calm and uh and a little bit
more light
mike tyson's going to vote who's he
going to vote for is he going to vote is
he going to vote for
joe jorgensen is that is that who he's
going to vote for he's going to vote for
someone named joe
you think so tell you i used to hang out
with uh
donald trump back in the day we used to
go and pick up ladies and uh
you know he never treated me fairly so
uh i'm going with joe biden
you think that's gonna happen no i can't
see him but i can see him voting for
trump tell me why i mean mike dyson's
been punched in the face a couple of
maybe two times i don't know where his
mind's at right now so he's gonna go a
little crazy who knows
let's get our audience crazy who do you
think he's voting for
i think he's gonna write in uh the tiger
on the ballot you think so yeah i think
he's gonna vote for the tiger
wow from hangover i like that
i think he's gonna bring in a whole new
candidate by the way i love the way that
mike tyson has reinvented himself yeah
he could have gone the way
of the typical washed up just like angry
beat up you know boxer yeah but he's
you know become more lighthearted
playful a pretty incredible sense of
humor about himself
within a split second he can harm
anybody in a room i mean there's only a
couple people in the world that can
probably take this guy
okay you know if he really wanted to in
a room he can do whatever he wants to do
but
you know he's trying to be a good dad he
makes an effort he called that
mayweather he says you think you're
tough he says
tell me if you walk you can't take your
kids to school tell me what you're doing
because this is what i do
tyson's got his own identity right now
and i like it and i think
knowing who he is the underdog guy i
think he's probably going to lean
leaning towards voting for trump well
and if nobody
if nobody that doesn't like you can beat
you up then
you kind of have the freedom to have
whatever kind of sense of humor but he
is fighting again against one of the
royal greatest boxers weeks ago yeah
okay
can we google when that fight is he's
tyson roy jones jr by the way audience
who you got in this fight mike tyson
versus roy jones jr
mike tyson obviously one of the greatest
heavyweights of all time roy jones jr
one of the greatest
middleweights who you got my prediction
in if it ends in the first two rounds is
tyson if it goes past two rounds it's
roy jones
just stamina simple i don't know speed
versus
i don't know i saw i watched his
training videos
i'm telling you tyson's man he looks
good
he looks good there's nobody what is
that fight no question about it he looks
too legends are scared to square off an
exhibition over cover over thanksgiving
weekend wow are we going where is it
going to be i don't know are we going to
check it out i think we should go
where's it going we got mike by the way
apparently they're going to be fighting
with social distancing so it's going to
be there
well you got ufc people fighting these
days so i think these guys are going to
do
we'll see what's going to happen with
that so who you're going with i'm
telling you make a prediction though
right now i could just say well i think
this is why
i think i think tyson is going to take
it in the first two rounds
you think it's just going to knock him
out yeah i think he's going to go in for
the kill
you got to realize weight difference
right i mean he's heavyweight that's
i pick my mike tyson the first two
rounds i got roy jones junior we're
gonna have a what round
i guess he's i think he's gonna win okay
so he's i gotta get
he says fans won't be allowed in
california is there really a market for
dude bring it to texas yes there is a
market for pay-per-view
tyson roy jones jr so you got tyson
you got tyson you got you got roy jones
i got roy jones jr can you predict the
round
i think it's gonna i think tight like
you said i think tyson's gonna get tired
after
three four rounds junior there's also an
age difference i feel like roy jones jr
is a few years younger kyle you want to
give me an answer on that
it's but not by far though it's like
five six years yeah five six years is a
big deal
you're fighting when you're 50. i don't
know
tyson's hungry he's hungry junior fifth
year wave of fame i think and
he's and he doesn't he's not a little
tyson
uh ty press it there you go 55.
roy jones is 51. he's right roy jones is
51 tyson is
50 so three years apart guys i forget
how good roy jones jr there was a time
that he was the best fighter no question
about he was better than floyd mayor no
question about his prime
no question about it let's talk a
business story let's talk a business
story i'm trying to see which business
story i want to get into here we've been
talking the gun business oh we've been
talking a lot of gun business let's pick
a business
you're having fun oh man yeah how about
tesla coming out with their 25 000
cars so tesla just announced elon musk
says tesla will offer an affordable
drive
a driverless car within three years
for 25 000 announced during
battery k uh battery car meeting
520 mile range on the car the new
battery uses large cells with a
simplified design and lower cost
materials that can be manufactured
faster and 56 percent cheaper than the
current technology what do you think
about this elon musk new car
uh 25 000 driverless car within three
years
is it gonna deliver within three years
no i okay go ahead
ladies first go ahead no i don't you're
just saying no he's not doing it no i
don't think it's gonna happen i mean
he's you know i mean i
i'm an elon fan i mean i think a friend
of the show we we talk to him
all the time he's we talk about him
every episode i think the guy's
brilliant
but i mean you know if he keeps smoking
weed with joe rogan
he might not get this done on time i
think it'll that'll inspire him to get
it done
way sooner so kidding me then he's got
to be back
and they got to smoke i think um
say it again pat they got to go back for
part two yeah i think so
i think look what's happening in
california these days what do we talk
about with governor newsom that he has
basically
he delivered an executive order banning
all new car sales uh that are gas
powered
by 2035. so in the next 15 years
no more new car sales in california will
have
will run on gasoline that's even more
wishful thinking okay all right i'm not
saying
that's going to happen or it's not going
to happen but that's the executive order
that gavin newsom uh
passed down so what does that you know
just go down this
has an executive order executive order
it's happening california kooky place
kooky place
uh we just came back from california
it's cookie place so what do you think
about it are you gonna
i think about it i mean look what are we
gonna do some so who does that help
what is the average cost of a tesla
right now 70 80 90 grand i don't think
it's
like 50 to 60k oh more than that it's 50
to 60. is it say 860k
okay so all he has to do is make more
and make him cheaper right i mean
he's i mean he's working on a supercar
right now that's going to go zero to 60
in less than
uh two seconds i mean less than two
seconds and it's gonna go 200
miles an hour but that's a completely
different story on what he's building
but who does this favor what governor
newsom is doing
it favors the the electronic car i
actually agree with you kai
you were saying something uh no the way
i mean the way he's going at it
is he's just making cheaper batteries
he's going back to the to the
the natural materials and looking okay
this is what's expensive
this is why uh electric cars are more
expensive
and then they're trying to find new ways
to create new batteries that are cheaper
that takes down the price and i think
with innovation and especially now with
gavin newsom's order
and where you're having other companies
also kind of lining up
that that is the way it's going and if
we look at the innovation of computers
and how
it's grown over time i mean i think
there's no doubt that eventually we'll
get to that point with cars too there we
go
that's kai ladies and gentlemen let's
not forget there's the competitor to
tesla that we don't hear that much about
this nikola which is tesla's first name
ironically yeah this nikola
they partnered up with was it gm okay
yes they partnered with gm and they're
going to be making their own
so i think the e the electronic car the
teslas the nikolas
that's a wave of the future whether it
happens in the next three years five
years ten years
we're on the we're on that questions i
have so many questions i mean how long
do these batteries last
you know how do you dispose of them when
do they need to be replaced because we
went through a very similar situation
with plastics
and if you've watched the documentary on
plastics and plastics was the wave of
the future
it was supposed to you know say you know
save us and be reusable and all this
stuff and now we have tons and tons of
trash
that's not biodegradable you know i have
questions about this i want to know
about
you know the the impact to you know the
environment
in the future and i don't think that he
that's been addressed you know and i
want to also know like
how can a how can a government how can a
governor put down an executive order
like that i mean
it could potentially just be overturned
when the next governor's elected
touche we'll see we'll see what's going
to happen i mean i can tell you
uh if newsom came up with that by 2035
if there was a way for him to try to
save elon from leaving california that
may have not been a bad strategy by the
way if it was a way for him to get
elon musk to say okay you're making this
a law i'll stay over here but again
tesla is a international product i don't
think he's going to sit there and just
the
the laws of california is going to say i
think that this is something that he
could do
to uh sway elon to stay in
california i just don't see long's
personality as a guy that belongs in
california i see elon is a texas guy i
see alana's a florida guy silana's a
tennessee guy
i don't see lana as a independent as a
california guy
yeah he's very independent he's got his
other way he's been blue pill and red
pill in
you know california for a long time yes
he has been he has been kevin newsom
uh what about him he was the u-haul
salesperson of the of the month was it
recently so he's doing great yeah very
impressive he's doing great that's pat
pat gave him that
mayor garcetti just announced two dozen
cities are announcing their own ubi
500 a month they want to pay to the
low-income families
in l.a los angeles the country's second
largest city merigar said he has pledged
to launch a program that includes a mix
of public and private money
he hinted the program could also help
immigrants
living in the country illegally who have
been written out of federal legislation
in los angeles the county says okay but
so you wrote the same thing twice in
copy paste okay got that so
so you got 500 500
a month 500 a month that he wants to pay
out as his own form of ubi
two dozen cities are agreeing to this
who does this help
who does this hurt who should care who
shouldn't care
the taxpayers should definitely care um
and i think we didn't we just do this
experiment with uh
with unemployment during covet and
stimulus checks didn't we just do
this experiment and and how many people
didn't want to go back to work
because they made too much money on
unemployment two-thirds of people were
getting paid
more to sit at home than they were when
working
i mean if it's you know and and then
it's it's companies
i think maybe a lot like yours that
suffer people don't want to come back to
work
you know and it's you know you're gonna
go where the money is
to me that seems very counterproductive
and what was what was what is
stimulating this decision like what is
what you know who is he
we we already have a myriad of programs
to help low-income people i don't
understand
why we why we need to continue to add on
top of that and i'm not saying that you
know
i'm not saying that you know poor people
are lazy that's not where i'm getting
from and that's not what i'm getting at
you know circumstances happen
i'm just wondering why these current
programs that we have don't seem to be
uh filling the void yeah you know i'm
not
so how many other cities other than la
have 25 cities paterson new jersey has
also pledged to follow a similar program
uh you're talking about oakland uh uh
mount vernon
some places in new york tacoma
washington patterson jersey long beach
some other areas
okay let's let's play a little game real
quick on where we are on
ubi right universal basic income yeah
i'm like 70 30 meaning
i'm 70 no 30
okay let me i see some benefits with
this all right let's list the pros and
cons and i'd love to get your responses
so what are the cons right the cons are
obviously it encourages
laziness it encourages people not to go
back to work uh disincentivizes work
um illegals maybe potential crim
criminals just straight-up losers would
be getting money to
sit at home and obviously taxpayers
socialism big government
there's a lot of bad on ubi what's the
good what's the good so obviously
people can avoid slipping into poverty
homelessness
some people could potentially have that
money to pay their bills maybe take more
risks
start more businesses that's an
opportunity right there
um and then obviously the big thing that
andrew yang talks about
is automation and robots are going to be
coming for your jobs
in the next 10 20 30 40 years so there's
pros and cons to this so i'm 70 30
um against ubi but i'm not 100 against
ubi
what say you to me a ubi
screams uh i can't compete in the world
it's green you know it screams it's not
encouraging people to
go into the trades which is so necessary
right now okay
so yeah so we're we're doing this this
whole
you know i think when when i was in high
school and you know during my college
years it was like you got to go to
college you're a loser
okay and then the trades suffered for it
right so
you know um you know welders and
gunsmithing and you know we get finding
a good mechanic god help us can we find
a good mechanic
you know what i mean and so all that
stuff suffered
and now the trades are making a comeback
totally agree and i think that
um you know if we if we say you know
we're going to give out this universal
basic income it's really just proving
that all of your programs that you've
done before
before this have failed because they're
out there
okay and you can and you can take
advantage of them so why do we need this
additional one we're disincentivizing
people
to either start businesses you know
there's micro loan programs and loan
programs for people who want to start
businesses
um and and then you know we don't we
don't we're not encouraging anybody to
think for themselves do for themselves
or
go into the much needed trades i'm i'm
in the trades
i'm in gunsmithing where are you on the
on the are you 100
80 90 50 50 like where are you on the
i'm zero percent
because we already have we already have
programs in place are you also zero
percent
let me tell you what i love about it i
love the i love that garcetti announces
to l.a you have no idea how much i love
it tell
ask me why i love it pat pat let me tell
you why i want to ask
why do you love it let me tell you why i
love it jay i'm gonna tell you why i
love it
and it's gonna be a different
perspective but i love
this stupidity of what la's about to do
do it go for it give people free money
here's what it's going to do look you
know what i'm all about is the following
okay if if taken off if if you
if you they say a very simple line
says if you don't take care of your
people somebody else will
right it's that simple now you know
you're going to lose certain people
culturally they fit in a different
culture etc etc
but if you don't take care of your
people somebody else will if you don't
take care of your woman
somebody else will if you don't take
care of your man someone else will
there's always going to be somebody else
that's willing to take care of what you
currently have it's that simple right
okay
you know la has a choice to offer this
ubi program to the people that they want
who's it going to attract
so imagine if you are in a different
county
and your county doesn't give you 500
okay
say i am the mayor of a complete
different city
i'm a mayor of a completely different
county different city that i'm running
it and
la announces they're giving 500 guess
who's leaving my city
i'm in love i'm like mayor garcetti
thank you
thank you because everybody that wants
free money and are moving to your county
thank you for cleaning out my county i'm
all with it
because i'm not going to lose my
business owners to your county oh no
i'm going to lose the people that want
free money to your county i appreciate
you
phenomenal job thank you so much for
doing this a guy came out
a couple years ago his v his story went
viral
he said i don't believe i need to make
more than 70 000 of your income
guy who wants this company you know what
the story is oh yeah of course so
so so so he ends up giving everybody a
salary those were making 10 bucks an
hour he takes them up to what
70 right and those that were making six
figures he takes them down to what
70. he was making a million dollar
income guess what he does takes himself
down to 70. you kind of get this so
people making less than 70 they're
saying what that's a place to be
man i'm loving this kind of a place
right i want to go work for somebody
that's automatically going to give me 70
000 all your income
you know how long that beautiful story
that was shared by the media lasted
less than two years you know why it's
not sustainable
it's not sustainable in companies it's
not sustainable in families
it's not sustainable in cities but i
love if i am a county next to la
i am saying please do it i'm begging you
do it
let's clean the house of my street i
will give you all the people that are
low income
let them come to your city it's up to
you you know
you know how this whole thing
conversation goes about taxes we're
sitting at rafi's place we're having a
friendly
best restaurant guy real quick pull up
dan price gravity that's the guy okay
70 grand so so so we're sitting at
rafi's place
and and at rafi's place the conversation
comes up about taxes
and our good friend steve uh uh uh there
you go
dan price is an american entrepreneur
he's a ceo of online credit processing
company
gravity payments which he started while
a student in seattle pacific university
he gained recognition when he
after he raised his company's minimum
wage to 70 000 and he slashed his wage
to 1.1 million dollars you got to read
the whole story minimum wage 70k i don't
think he lowered
uh minimum weight 70k minimum weight 70k
which anyway
catastrophic when you do something like
that catastrophic when you do something
like that let's talk more about rafi's
place and your friend steve so you guys
debate over taxes we sit down we start
talking about taxes
okay shout out to steven if he's
listening yeah it's steve
i'm not going to say who said what but
one of the guys if he wants to come and
defend it here it's a whole different
conversation
one the guy says i think we need to
raise the taxes on rich people
i said oh really he said yes i said
what's considered rich says you know
these people that make a hundred million
dollars a year
i said i said wait wait wait wait wait
who's rich
the people that make 100 million dollars
i want you to look at that indian couple
right behind us remember that indian
couple
right behind so what do you think i said
what do you think they make
and he says i don't know i said what do
you think the average person here makes
i said i said what'd you make last year
watch out your friends about to drink i
said what'd you make last year he gives
the number
i said how many people in this room made
your kind of money i said if i told
everybody in this room right now that
you made that kind of money what would
they consider
rich i said they think you need you need
to be taxed a lot so who are you to
determine who needs to be taxed
i think there's got to be a tax for
talented people that don't use their
talents
for me it's the other way around i'm
being dead serious with you right
if you're talented and you are not using
your talent and you're sitting around i
think we need to tax you the highest wow
not the other way around because if a
person is busting their butt
going out there creating jobs using
their talents to create an economy for
other people
that person needs to pay less taxes if
the person that's not using their
talents that person needs to be taxed
more i mean isn't there a story about it
with the guy
and you know with five talents three
talents
one talent all this other stuff you got
to put your talents to use i think too
many times we
you know we we like to demonize these
guys that are going out and creating
economy and jobs
and and not the other way around the
people that don't want to use their
talents i know
how many people you know adam how many
people you know
that are more talented than you that are
broke oh there's a lot
of people why are they broke and they're
so talented i don't know what so they're
just they can't get it together i'll
give you my favorite quote
literally of all time let's hear it so
have you ever seen the movie the bronx
tale
of course okay mickey married yes yeah
mickey man
robert de niro yes okay mickey mantle uh
robert de niro
when's the last time mickey mouse paid
your bills exactly yeah
my favorite quote literally of all time
um
he says the saddest thing in life is
wasted talent i remember i wrote that
quote down because there was a time in
my life
where i remember saying i'm so talented
i can do whatever i want to do i can
literally become who i want to become
but i'm wasting my time just doing
nonsense partying in south beach and i
said the saddest thing in life
is wasted talent i heard that i wrote
that down yeah i wrote that down
and i read that every it's i still have
a plaque yeah in my room with that
saying so i i agree you know what i
would do
if i was a governor or small state just
to do a project
eight years if i'm a governor a small
state i'd flip taxes
i'd flip it i'd make it progressive but
the other way around
the less you make the more you get the
less you make the more you pay
mind blown the less you make the more
taxes you pay the more you make the less
taxes wow
that's going to get people that's
capitalism people are going to be
hustling guess what that does
guess what that does you know what it
does it's going to motivate people the
people on the bottom are going to say
screw this guy i don't like this guy no
problem go to l.a i think he's just
going to move garcetti would love you
but the other people are getting like
shoot let me this is that my game
come to your state you come to my state
you the more
the more jobs you create the less tax
listen
compensation structures are tax
companies
if you think about our tax plan is a
comp plan that's all it is at a sales
company
their comp plan is a tax plan and i
don't know a single company
that grows in sales where they charge
the people that make more money
and they pay them less commission let me
get this straight so if i come to a
company and i'm doing sales
and the more value and revenues i bring
to the money don't i make more
commission instead of less commission
what sales organization that grows says
the more money you make we pay you less
commission have you ever heard of an
organization
but taxes do and all of these americans
have bought into this progressive tax
system for what
wow who said this because somebody said
the more money you make the more money
you should pay no should be the other
way around
i say if you are able to create 50 jobs
if i'm running a city and i tell you
you create 50 jobs an average salary of
50 000
of your income okay does that help my
city out
yeah of course does it help your city
out yeah you create how hard is it to
create 50 jobs for a city
not wait a minute not easy if it's easy
not easy not easy it's
very hard yes i don't want you to pay
taxes you'll have the lowest level of
taxes you pay
you create 50 jobs in my city are you
kidding me
you're a hero no it's the other way
around you created 50 jobs
and you're making money off of these
people and you make 2.2 million dollars
last year
shame on you you rich man what do you
mean shame on you
it's the other way around you you are
you have this degree
you are so smart you are so well read
you know about philosophy you've read
all the books in the world
and you are unemployed for nine straight
months
and you're blaming society for it no
you're going to be taxed at the highest
level wow you don't like the city go to
a different city taxing
wasted talent i've never heard that in
my life let me put some intense stuff
but let me put it to you this way you
know what are the chance of somebody
getting elected on that campaign
no zero yeah yeah you ain't going to get
elected on something like that but do
you know how
on point that message is my mind is so
yes
boom my mind is guys give a thumbs up if
you like pat's point on that that was
something it'll never happen folks
i just want you to know this give a
thumbs up not in a time where all these
rich people are demonized and
everybody else who's unemployed not
getting a job as a hero of america today
i've
i can't understand that what's the
what's the percentage i heard this one
time and but i can't remember it like
how uh how much of like basically the
total tax burden
does the like top one percent carry
don't they pay like almost half of the
actual nation's taxes
yes most of it of course they do of
course they do
uh uh um pull that up but but look
here's here's
here's here's what i'm all about man
this is what i'm all about
for me you know when i see somebody like
when you and i spoke
perfect example this is my wiring i
can't help myself i'm wired like this
when you and i spoke the first time how
how many years ago was this eight years
ago nine years ago 2012.
so i see adam okay if you ever go to
you should go to an event without him
okay
when you go to internet with adam if you
go to the acting school
you know with adam within five minutes
adam knows everybody
i was like hey what's up i don't know
adam but adam approached me i didn't
approach adam i'm at the gym doing my
regular back workout i'm doing adam
starts coming what's this what's up man
your muscles what do you do
tell me so and then every time adam's
talk everywhere i go
out everybody knows adam how the hell
does everybody know adam how long have
you been the insurance
every once i'm like dude listen
i pulled him aside one day i said you
are so flippant talented you need to be
on tv you need to be on camera you're a
camera guy
he says what do you mean i said you
don't need to write you don't need to
start a podcast
you're handsome you're good-looking you
got a good voice you got a good sense of
humor you need to be on tv
he starts doing videos okay this is a
talented
guy i mean he's got a big upside and
like this guy's got to do something with
his talent
now him adam is a cash millionaire now
you weren't 10 years ago
no you're now a cash millionaire right
you're a saver you're very responsible
saver and
yes take care of two cats you got a
little weird but it is what it is
okay so now watch this gift i watch
jarrah
yeah when i left watching jarrah i
couldn't help myself
i'm like this is talented human being oh
my gosh
her storytelling her sense of humor i
could not believe
i'm sitting there i would have normally
checked my phone a hundred times listen
to class
i didn't even check my phone for four
hours i'm just glued that's the same
when she's telling her story i walked
out and i said dude
we got to get her on the podcast now
here's the thing with jared jared's not
an online personality
jarrah's not an influencer meaning she's
not like she has her own youtube channel
she has her own podcast
after this i would love to see jared be
all over the place because i think jared
is a talented person
everything i see i see when i saw sam
the first time he took care of me
three years ago 20 i don't know what the
time was okay two and a half years ago
wherever it was
i'm like i feel safe around sam
sam makes you feel safe and then i saw
how sam took charge of everything sam
wasn't working for me two and a half
years because is there anything i can
get you
uh are you okay are these people
bothering you do i need you to i'm like
dude i don't pay you why are you doing
this then i told them what i said i said
listen if you ever want to run
you got a job with me you tell me when
you want to do it and then he came
he contacted we figured something out he
came out here to dallas but i saw the
talent of him
leading people first time i sat down
with kai you know yesterday you did the
interview with uh what's the guy's name
you interviewed yesterday the the
daryl davis daryl davis what an amazing
guy i can't wait to know who
daryl davis is i'm supposed to do the
interview and last minute the only
person i've ever given an interview for
my career is who
to you i said adam you're gonna do this
interview i'm not gonna do the interview
it's on you
so adam does the interview yesterday
crushes it an hour and a half interview
ends up being six hours
it's a six hour interview that's the
only problem half hour we ran out of
tape
all our cameras are done davis and i
guess
old school tape all the tickets okay do
you know who daryl davis is kkk guy that
converts people that guy that converted
they made a movie about amazing but you
know what happened at 11 o'clock
i get a text at 11 o'clock you know who
it's from kai
what does kai say pat don't worry he's
going to be ready
we're going home right now he's prepared
for it tomorrow he's going to do fine i
didn't tell kai to do that
kai chose to do that see it's so
attractive
when people use their talents it's the
most
unattractive thing for me i cannot tell
you how unattractive it is
when somebody doesn't use their talents
it's so unattractive
and we have become the nation that wants
to applaud victims
we have become the nation that wants to
plot every
everything that happens i was having
anxiety i have a mental issue i'm in
depression
first of all half the time we're
depressed and we have mental issues
life is freaking complicated marriage is
annoying half the time raising kids
how many people want their kids [ __ ]
on them all the time how many more
diapers you want me to change how many
times does this kid have to
pee on me changing the diapers i'm
checking the phone all of a sudden i'm
sensing my
cheek getting wet and warm i don't have
a clue why this is happening my
son is peeing on me what a wonderful
life that's parenting
okay you got pee over here i'm like oh
my gosh pee and he's smiling at you
peeing on you
you know what do you do to this kid
happy birthday hey man phenomenal job
buddy you know
life is complicated man life is weird
but you got to use your talents
so all this stuff about giving money
away you know what an you know how i
perceive when somebody wants to give you
free money
let me tell you how i look at free money
so weird how i look at free money i have
such a hard time taking money from
people
when somebody gives you free money to me
it's like
you think i can't do something
it's it's a way of thinking it's
insulting it's insulting
it's insulting if somebody says here no
man i got it
little bit i get it a little bit maybe a
week maybe two weeks but i got it
i don't want to sit there and rely on
somebody for like a hand up instead of a
um situation so for me man listen if if
it's not going to happen i have no
desire of politics
uh the more more i think about it the
more and more i just know it's not going
to be something i'm going to be
entertaining
but if i ever ran a state or if i ever
rent a country
you wouldn't like my tax system if you
did love my tax system it's because
you're improving if you didn't i would
send you to mayor garcia
city or county or state that he's
governing but you wouldn't like the
state i'd be running because i would
want people that are using their talents
and that's not a popular message today
no i've heard pat say a lot of powerful
things that might have taken the cake
right there other than that synergy
uh rant you went on that blew my mind
um when on the earlier podcast that was
probably one of my favorites i don't
know that i have any mind left
uh at this point i mean it's what you
know it's almost 10 o'clock i
i have to say that this this whole thing
has me you know thinking like the way
that you guys think in the way that you
interact with each other and the things
you said
really kind of have got me just you know
my wheels are turning up here because
i i don't i don't do things like this
you know what i mean you know people
will have me on their podcast and
they'll go
uh you know like well tell me about how
you train women and how they learn
versus how men learn but it's never been
a conversation like this but i'll tell
you what what what
has happened is you know i didn't want
to be here
i didn't want to you know i don't want
to sit on a on a podcast that has 2
million followers
you know i never i didn't get into this
because i wanted to
be the face of something right but when
enough people
tell you if not you then who like who
else is going to talk about this and
it's not that i'm the only one i mean
you know amy robbins is doing a great
job antonio okafor is doing a great job
there's a lot of women that are out
there really speaking about 2a
but we need more like we need more women
because we're
the ones that need it the most i think
probably out of almost anybody
i agree you know what i mean and and
that's arguable okay
but you know we are we are the weaker
sex
um you know the human traffickers aren't
snatching the babies up from their
daddies
they're looking for the distracted mom
that they're banking on
is you know unprepared unaware and
unarmed
okay and then human trafficking is a
huge problem that we have right now and
i think that's a
whole podcast episode in and of itself
but the point is that i didn't want to
be here i didn't consider this a talent
i didn't consider this you know i didn't
i didn't look at my 23
year old self you know when that had my
24 year old self when that happened to
me and go you know what i'm going to go
i'm going to start a company yep
i'm gonna start teaching guns that's
what i'm gonna do for a living i never
thought that
in a million years but the more that i
started doing it and the more people
that were taking my classes
it's not necessarily that i'm just this
wonderful awesome instructor it's just
that i have a perspective
and i have a passion for it now and it's
you know and that's what you have to do
is you have to attach yourself to a
purpose
and that's and that's what makes you so
it's you know i never wanted to be here
but i mean i'm honored
to be here and i think that the message
needs to get out you know if i'm the one
that has to tell it
i hope more people contact you i hope
you get more people that are messaging
you and getting getting wanting to get
you to get exposed because
i mean sharing your story because this
message needs to be heard but let's do
this
i want to finish up with the soro story
kai can you pull up the soros video i
don't know if you guys saw what happened
with soros
it's a little disturbing okay it's a
little disturbing for me
and if if you have the video go click on
uh do you have it or you don't have a
kai i think you do have it somewhere
there is there
no not that one although that's a cool
video i saw that it was good you added
that video by the way to it i saw it
last night
uh uh uh just kai if you can't find it
just go type in
yeah so i don't know if you guys saw
what happened the other day luis did you
see this
have you guys seen what happened with
soros and newt gingrich the other day on
fox
no you didn't see it i did do you know
who george soros is
no idea okay so we're gonna we're gonna
find
it's a legendary hockey player who
played for the kings
as the goalie uh uh a great defender
let me see move off of it because it's
the video that's like minute okay go to
minute 46 the 275 000. yeah
click on that one you open it up like
that interesting
all right fast forward a little bit guy
[Music]
uh keep going droid by this point
keep going keep going
for us i don't think youtube's live look
the number one problem in almost all
these cities
is george soros elected left-wing
anti-police pro-criminal district
attorneys
who refuse to keep people locked up
just yesterday they put somebody back on
the street who's wanted for two
different murders
in new york city uh you cannot
solve this problem and both harris and
biden
have talked very proudly
progressive pro-criminal and
overwhelmingly elected with george soros
as well watch this and they're a
major cause of the violence we're seeing
because they keep putting the violent
criminals back on the street
i'm not sure we need to bring georgetown
to this i'm not sure we need to bring
george for watching wow i was going to
say you get the last word speaker
he paid for it i mean why can't we
discuss the fact that millions of
dollars
i agree with you george doesn't need to
be a part of this conversation
who is she okay
so it's for both all right okay
okay positive who is she first of all
that that
this upset you deeply the other day no
no no
that's by the way this is not this is
not about fox i've never seen this on
cnn or msnbc
this is this is this is very
uncomfortable saying you can't talk
about something
what what or someone first of all who
were what was that all about what was
that all about i mean
when you see this guy spending the kind
of money
to help people getting elected in
small communities and you know you're
spending the money you are doing all
this is proven this is the stuff that
this guy is doing it's been proven many
times by people
regarding what soros has done what newt
gingrich all of a sudden you can't say
that why can't you say that
why yesterday i was watching a jimmy
kimmel now jimmy fallon
had somebody on who talked about what
happened with brianna taylor
okay and the last four minutes of that
interview
if you watch with brianna take it with
the the lady that spoke
can you type in jimmy fallon and then go
uh today solve for today
go jimmy fallon and uh on the filters go
to okay search
then go to just go to his channel and
i'll take you to the video
go to his channel actually right there
that's the lady right there um
yeah right there uh joyride go lower two
more one more
okay right there if you watch this go to
minutes
eight joyride is a big nbc and she is in
the nbc let's go to minute eight
and if you listen surprised was in the
freddie gray case in baltimore when they
were charged
the surprise is when there are charges
and that's only because maryland
i i highly recommend people watch this
because when i watch the last four
minutes of what she says
first of all she made it seem like all
cops are bad cops
she made it seem like we should get rid
of all cops
i mean how was the executive producer
not jumping and saying wait a minute
listen listen
you were escorted here by cops we are
protected by cops what are we doing
it's not all of them it's a small
percentage of them you don't hear
anybody stop and do stuff
you can't say the word sorrows is sora
is advertising a lot of money on fox
what soros doing for fox's producer to
say you can't mention the name
newt gingrich the man who had a 22
percent lead
years ago when he was running for office
he was crushing on the debates and then
he dropped off
because if some stories came out about
him this is the same guy that worked
with
clinton in 94 was a manatee or time
magazine man of the year
he was the one that helped with the
economy him and clinton worked together
here's a guy that knows how to unite and
work with an
opposing side he can't say anything that
guy cannot say anything
executive producer comes and says you
can't say that it's verbotem
very uncomfortable when i saw that well
and the woman in the previous video who
said that george soros doesn't need to
be a part of the conversation was
actually former obama administrative
administration state department staffer
marie harf
she was yeah the blonde girl
the blonder was adam do you have
anything to sand this are you just kind
of flabbergasted i mean it's good
this is actually perfect timing the the
fact that i did this
interview with daryl davis yesterday
yeah again if you guys have not
in our audience have not seen anything
with daryl davis please google him
check out what he has done he's been on
rogan he's been on cnn he's got
documentaries
and he basically meets with kkk klansmen
and convinces them or
sparks something in their mind to get
them to leave the clan
okay so one of the i'll give you a few
of his perspectives and quotes and he
says
i may not agree with what you say but i
defend
your right to say it cool that's the
first amendment
and for sure we need different
perspectives there's nothing that we
have this is the first amendment
i might not agree with what you're
saying but you can say it this is
america
right and his keys and it's what makes
america different than everywhere else
exactly i don't get that so you need to
listen
to other people and respect other
people's opinions yeah but
listen and respect this is bigger than
that though this is bigger than that
this is
this is controlling the narrative with
fox
this is fox uh uh having
having being afraid of somebody saying
something the host
is stopped and says wait you can't say
that that's not true
that's like in the middle of a debate
when when you see
hillary is debating trump and trump says
something
the moderator says you're wrong rather
than asking a question but doesn't say
you're wrong to hillary
let them debate then you say you're
wrong the next day you can't jump in and
do this but the media is now doing this
very disturbing to me at the highest
level i would like to see if there's
anything more like that or if that's
just a one-time
incident the mission of journalism has
become very diluted and mutated yeah
it's
it's a it's a great time for a media
company to get started i can tell you
that for a moment by the way
if you if you've enjoyed if you've
enjoyed today's
show i am putting jarrah's instagram
account right there in the comment
section if you see not the comments
section but on the chat section
go give her a follow send her some love
jared it's been great having you on
on uh on the podcast here lots of crazy
topics we've uh talked about
and if you are still on with us press
that thumbs up
share the podcast comment below press
the subscribe button
and click on that upload button to be
alerted the next time we go live
the next time we go live will be
following
tuesday on the debate at night remember
next tuesday is going to be the debate
on the 29 between biden and trump
it's going to get pretty hot so join us
on that debate we'll watch it together i
want to hear your thoughts
let's have a party together watching the
first debate because some tells me
if trump and biden are going to be
involved it's going to be entertaining
it's going to be a blast
and we want to have you join us next uh
tuesday night the 29th tuesday i don't
know the exact time we're going to put
the time up
on what the debate's going to be it's
going to be an all-night thing it's
gonna
we're gonna have a good time bring your
sleeping bag sleepy joe will be there
donald trump will be there
have a great weekend everybody love you
bye bye bye bye
you